ce que je sais c'est que senna en 2016
et le rapporteur général a souligné la
fragilité de cette taxe par rapport aux
directives européennes
aujourd'hui c'est clair il va falloir
qu'on trouve une solution de 10
milliards cette solution il va falloir
que nous en parlions avec gouvernement
parce que nous sommes des gens qui
assumons nos responsabilités et au sénat
nous devrons être de ceux qui
contribuent à la réflexion sur la
solution se renvoyer savoir si c'est
nicolas sarkozy
moi je retiens une seule chose c'était
dans le projet de françois hollande on
ne ramène à la date 2012 au projet de
françois hollande nous l'avions mis en
garde
nous n'avons pas été écoutés et on en
voit les conséquences alors
manifestement le gouvernement veut faire
un texte budgétaire
voilà spécial particulier à la fin
d'année ce qu'on appelle un collectif
budgétaire et du projet de loi de
finances rectificative âgées doit de
finances rectificative pour être
pardonné mois mais est ce que c est ce
que c est ce que c'est une voie là est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça si tu
as écouté on va voir le projet tel qu'il
est la bonne formule gouvernement mort
n'a informé
est ce qu'il faut aller vite le
gouvernement d'informer je vais voir à
que rapporteur général
le président de la commission des
finances là aussi il faut qu'on pense
quel est l'intérêt supérieur de notre
pays est ce que c'est de se renvoyer le
ballon de rugby pour savoir si c'était
en 1995 que tout cela mais l'arrêt la
même décision du conseil s'il lâche
lionel man 1 et ya urgence la haye et il
faut qu'on apporte des réponses qui ne
conduisent pas un nouveau déséquilibre
budgétaire dans notre pays pas qu'il
faut aller vite
2 qu'est faut aller vite clair mais ça
vous démontre que ces taxes on invente
sur des coins de table ou sur des
pulsions pour faire plaisir à une
clientèle par rapport à une autre
c'est une mauvaise manière de faire de
la politique si j'ai un reproche à faire
dans le projet de françois hollande
c'est que ce type de proposition elle
été lancée comme un élément un peu
contre la finance contre les entreprises
y envoient le résultat